décollage réussi hier soir pour les
quatre touristes américains dont le
milliardaire john isaac man qui a
affrété le vol ils passeront trois jours
autour de la terre plus loin que la
station spatiale internationale
chaque jour eh bien il faut environ 15
fois le tour du globe ont été marqués
par deux autres vols de milliardaire
richard branson à bord de vedettes
galactique et plus tard de jeff besos
avec sa société blue origin mais à quoi
sert ce tourisme spatial comme
l'impression que ça sert surtout les
plus fortunés d'entre nous
mais après donc le tourisme spatial il
faut se poser la question où est ce
qu'on va aller plus loin est ce que ces
réserves est justement à ces gens là
mais il faut se poser des questions sur
le le coût écologique le coût social de
ce genre de deux missions cette mission
aux baptisés inspiration 4 servirait
également à approfondir les
connaissances sur le corps humain des
analyses seront effectuées sur le rythme
cardiaque des passagers sur leur sommeil
ainsi que sur la capacité cognitive un
rêve pour plusieurs mais sans doute
inaccessible
le gros désavantage c'est que il ya au
petit le mans aucune régulation sur
l'espace espace appartient à tout le
monde ça c'est très bien c'est pour ça
qu'il ya pas de régulation mais en même
temps là on a l'impression qu'il
appartient simplement milliardaire et ça
c'est gênant en fait le coach voyage n'a
pas été dévoilé mais selon un rapport
gouvernemental
il s'établirait à plus de 200 millions
de dollars américains soit plus de 50
millions de dollars le siège
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal